the left is willing to tear away the
Munir of civilization in order to
achieve Brett Cavanaugh's defeat even
the ACLU a group supposedly dedicated to
protecting the rights of the accused a
group that doesn't even take positions
on judicial nominees broke its
long-standing policy this weekend thanks
to the allegations against Kavanagh
yep you heard that right an organization
that has spent decades defending people
accused of crimes against due process
violations now says Brett Kavanaugh
should be kept off the Supreme Court
without any any corroborate of evidence
of a 36 year old allegation so will the
bet pay off for Democrats who knows
maybe Republicans will stand up a week
from now maybe Kavanaugh will still sit
on the court but one thing is for
certain Democrats who sold their soul to
maintain federally protected abortion on
the Supreme Court cannot cannot be
trusted with power if Democrats take the
Senate more than the Supreme Court is at
stake if they can ruin Brett Kavanaugh
by running roughshod over his rights
what do you think they'll do to your
rights show up to vote on November 6th